The following is the production of Frank Defratus and the Internet Red V of Holography.
We have to fight faster.
Annihilate.
Hill!
Till!
Hell!
Shut up!
Hello, this is Frank Defraitas, and welcome to HoloTalk, the Internet's laser and holography talk show.
Our toll-free number is 1-800-4583525, or you can send an email to Holotalk at PoloWorld.com.
We've got telephone calls, we've got emails, we've got special guests coming up.
So thank you for tuning in.
And let's get this week's show on the road.
Hello, everybody, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk.
I'm sorry we had to go through a couple weeks of repeats.
Uh the first week actually we were uh I was actually trying to uh contact Jimmy Wolford uh down in Panama and I continuously got uh the international operator that said no it no lines were available.
So uh we're still gonna work with getting Jimmy on the show and we're probably going to uh do an interview with him late at night when there are more phone lines open into Panama from the United States.
Uh last week I had some surgery done and uh just couldn't get a chance to uh have the show done.
So uh we're back here this week in full swing.
Thank you very much.
I I did get a few emails from you, and it meant quite a bit to me getting emails uh saying uh that you hope everything was okay.
Uh I had a tumor removed, and so far so good.
Everything looks okay.
So we're back in the swing of things here with HoloTalk.
This week's guest is Alan Rhodey from Ross Books, and uh Ross Books, of course, as you may already know, is the publisher of the uh world-famous holography handbook, which got so many holographers started in the field to begin with, including myself back in 1983 when I got my own studio together.
And also the Holography Marketplace, which is a reference book for people who are looking for uh companies to do business with in the field of holography.
So both of these things are very driving forces in the field of philography, and they've all come out of the publishing house of Ross Books.
What's going to be interesting about this interview is Alan's going to tell us about a very uh incredible uh portable holographic camera that Sony's just developed.
So I'm not going to go into any details with any explanation here.
I'll let Alan do that when he comes on in a few moments.
Just to let you know, every other week we're going to do our uh listeners' call-ins and also their email.
So if you have any questions about the fields of lasers and holography, you can send them through uh toll-free.
You can call on the phone, 1800-458-3525.
Or you can send an email to HoloTalk at HoloWorld.com, and I'll just go through reference materials and see if I can't get the answer to your questions.
And uh if you happen to call in, we'll use your voice on the air.
And if you happen to write the email in, we'll be more than happy to read your email question uh during the show.
So let's move on.
Uh I just saw a a study that showed that the average listening time to a real audio presentation, this was done by Real Networks, uh, is four minutes.
Four minutes is the average listening time to any audio presentation on the web.
So we're going to try and cut back the show a little bit.
Sometimes we're 40 minutes long, sometimes we're 30 minutes long, but uh we realize that not everyone has a lot of time to sit and listen at their computers to the show, so we're going to just try and uh keep with the pertinent information during the shows and cut out some of the uh the chit chat and this and that and try and get the uh show times down a little bit that they're a little bit more manual manageable both for us to produce them and also for you to listen to.
Without taking out any of the uh exciting content or w what many of you feel, but you've said that it's exciting content anyway.
I don't want to start bragging about my own show here.
So uh let's move on to the interview with Alan Roy, who's very interesting, was nice talking to him.
He's uh uh going away on vacation to Hawaii, so we want to wish him uh a real happy vacation.
There's nothing like getting away from it all for a week or two just to clear the head out and get the cobwebs out of the head.
So Alan, you have a good time in Hawaii.
If you get a chance to log on and you're listening to the show, I hope uh everything's going well.
So let's move on.
This is our interview with Alan Roy from Ross Books.
Ross Books.
Yes, it's Alan Roadie there.
Speaking.
Alan, this is Frank Defradis.
Hey Frank, how are you?
Okay, how you doing?
I'm fine, thanks.
Could you tell us a little bit about what your company's doing?
I know you have the holography handbook.
Sure.
Well, I wanted to uh you know, I I just zapped you an email, just you remember you said is there any questions you might want to ask?
Yeah.
Um I just came back from FBI and I just wrote this big article on uh the Sony thing on the new portable uh instant po uh portrait system.
Oh, it's incredible, yeah.
Yeah, that was pretty cool.
Now this this is being manufactured by Sony.
Right.
What's what's a little a little bit of the news on that?
Okay, are we are we live?
I'm recording it, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Hold on there.
I gotta get a sip of coffee here.
Okay, go ahead.
I have some ice tea here.
You sip some coffee, I'll sip some iced tea.
This is informal.
Uh basically, Sony just unveiled the first uh fully portable portrait hordex stereogram portrait printing system.
By portable.
Our idea of portable sometimes means like a walkman.
Right, and it is something like that.
It can be used outdoors.
It's uh basically uh you sit in front of a scanning digital camera that's on a rail, and the rail's about three, four feet long.
The camera travels down the rail, it takes two hundred and twenty-five uh separate images that it feeds into an image processing unit, you know, just through a wire.
Okay.
And the image processing unit's located in a box about the size of a desktop copying machine.
Wow.
It goes through the image processor, the Mr.
Processor, takes all the different parallax views and regenerates two hundred and ninety-five different views left to right, um, sends them into uh an optics board located on a little isolation platform built into this thing.
Get out.
And the uh the condensed images are well, actually the images are shown on a um an L C D screen.
It's a spatial light modulator valve, they call it, and it's uh condensed into a vertical strip onto uh uh diffuser diffusure screen and then it's recorded with a little green laser, um, a solid state laser, uh directly on a piece of DuPont photopolymer.
Uh it takes each exposure is a quarter second, and each exposure cycle is um uh half a second, I believe.
Mm-hmm.
And it takes an exposure.
They invented a new type of film transport mechanism kind of based on a V CR and a Walkman.
I mean Sony knows how to do that thing and the old system of just like s sandwiching a piece of film between two pieces of glass or whatnot, uh it just uh there's too many stability problems and they couldn't go fast enough.
So they invented a pinch roller thing similar to the inside.
It reminds me of a Walkman by the diagram where the the film is kinda looped around and it presses up against the exposure fast enough against the aperture fast enough for a quick exposure and nothing moves.
Goes and does you know two hundred and ninety five of these little vertical slits, it takes a hundred and forty seven seconds, so um a little over two minutes, the film travels in automatically into um under a UV lamp extrater and a little baking chamber and outputs a piece of plastic within three minutes with a a f a stereogram hologram on photopolymer about three inches by two inches at the moment.
Mm-hmm and it's got full horizontal parallax and it can capture uh a couple seconds of animation.
We saw uh one of the guys you know he sneezed as you walk by so the couple seconds of animation there.
And they say, well once they get some more uh colored diode lasers in there because they wanted to operate off household current they can make full collar ones with the um DuPont uh panchromatic film and the film can be loaded into a cartridge so basically it's intended for an office worker.
Sony actually says, you know, we're really not interested in holographic portraits, but once you can feed they think stereograms are the best way to present three D digital information.
That's the bottom line.
So the the fact that it has a camera in it, you're taking portraits is almost incidental to them.
They want to make a a hard copy 3D output device.
Wow.
They call their holo printer because it's based around the old integral hologram.
It goes back to the early San Francisco days.
Certainly.
Yeah.
Whoever thought.
It's kind of a variation on that and you know, it's got Sony's name on it.
Now they previewed at the SPIE show, um they previewed the holograms.
They didn't bring the machine in but they had full schematics and photos of the thing, and it's about the size of a uh a desktop copier, a b a big um scanner or printer.
Yeah.
So it's fully in t and it's it's light tight and it has internal isolation on the optics, so you can pick the thing up and put it wherever you want.
Did they give any range of price on this?
No, right now it's all R and D.
What's your guess?
What do you think something like this look?
Five figures or six figures?
So it didn't seem like it was so esoteric.
They're just the first ones to really put all the component, yeah, and upgrade it and and put it all in one box, and they can afford, I would assume that laser in there is probably, you know, new fifty thousand dollars, but it's Sony, you know, they can they probably have pull with the laser company.
Um it's basically I think that is the main expense.
Once you have a film transport mechanism, that's you know, kind of just that's what they guys specialize in.
It didn't seem anything more complex than you know, a V C R certainly.
Yeah.
And uh, you know, i if you if if the digital input is formatted correctly, you know, through their processor, um, which is you know, proprietary.
Um it's got I think he said two hundred and fifty six megs of RAM in there and um you know, that's kind of the heart of the machine.
Everything else, they said, Well, we can make bigger holograms if we have bigger optics.
The film's already in twelve inch wide widths, so you know, they can feed it through it.
It's just a matter of engineering at that point.
Well, and you're doing a story for a uh publication?
I'm actually doing it for a um a web uh uh a web page and I'll try to market it to you know any magazine that I can.
I just want to let our viewers know that uh while you're listening to the show you can go to the Ross web page itself.
You want to tell them how how they can find it?
What is it?
What Rossbooks.
Rossbooks.com.
And I'll have a link on the page and you can exit the real audio player just by clicking on the browser and bringing it to the front.
You don't have to sit there staring at the screen while the uh show's playing.
You can visit Ross Books right on the web while you're listening to the show.
Now I logged on about two hours ago, so I didn't get the email.
I'm sorry about that.
But uh whatever you want to cover we can cover.
Great.
What was what was some of the other things you had in your email?
Well we saw some uh of the new emulsions, uh the new silver halide emulsions now that obviously Agva's not in the game, other people have to take up the slack.
And some of the holographers have been experimenting with the different emulsions now for about six months.
So we're starting to see some of the results.
Some nice results.
We saw some very nice results with the German emulsions, HRT, mm-hmm.
Very high contrast, give you some really nice blacks in the background if it's processed properly.
It's a little slow, but people are doing things to speed it up a little bit.
For reflection holography, these were reflection holograms.
Reflection holograms, yeah.
There's silver halide emulsions that are kinda hard to get for your average high school teacher now or you know, yeah, that's a sin.
That's really a shame.
Uh you know, the younger kids, that's that's the next generation that has to come up with this field, you know.
Correct, and then there's just uh there's a few distributors that are still carrying the old Ag VA stocks uh book, the holography handbook is built around the ACSO emulsions, so we're basically, you know, gathering information to for all these people and letting them know where they can buy the stuff.
Um Slavich, the Russian manufacturer, is bringing out some very h nice emulsions, very high quality emulsions.
People are getting very good results on that.
The Chinese are starting to develop their own emulsions, uh, company called Holt Door.
They have some US distribution.
We're getting preliminary results back on that.
Umica um is developing some emulsions suitable for industrial use and um we're looking forward to checking all these out and uh doing some comparisons.
What version is the holography handbook in now?
Uh the handbook we've just revised with some less toxic chemistries.
That was about two years ago, and now we're revising it again to um you know reflect the situation with the new emulsions.
You know that book got me uh got me on the road with holography.
Same with everybody.
I I still have that book, and I really need to take a Polaroid photo of this book so that you can see the condition that it's in.
I mean, it is just totally ripped apart.
Fantastic.
Which is a good sign.
That's a good sign because that means that book's been used.
We get the dog eared copies every once in a while.
I have to I have to show you this book.
This has got to be the best one yet.
We still sell it all over the world.
We're actually uh we were talking to somebody about a Chinese translation recently because it still seems to be one of the best uh you know lab manuals that you can take in there and uh do a step by step.
Well the only thing I could do before the holography handbook came out was just follow holography.
Because I s I started following it when the Museum of holography opened in New York but I couldn't do any holograms but then I caught onto the holography handbook and brought a copy of that home and I would say within maybe about ten days after getting that book I had my first hologram made.
That quick you know back in my younger days.
And we're also we're getting ready to put out the seventh edition of the holography marketplace.
Mm-hmm.
That's the newest edition that's a great resource.
Yeah it's 22 holograms in it this year.
Uh it's two hundred and forty pages.
We've got nine chapters of really nice information, informative stuff and nine hundred or so listings in the international uh database of uh holography related businesses.
That's worth its price just for the holograms that are in there.
A big 2295.
Yeah.
You you couldn't buy all those holograms that are in that book.
Well you have especially nice ones.
On the cover of this year we're doing uh photopolymer.
It's a computer generated image and it was produced by Crystal holographics on DuPont's Photopolymer.
Uh it's fairly big and it's a nice one.
Um we have some dot matrix holograms in the book.
There's some two D's, there's some two D three D's, there's three Ds, there's photopolymer and embossed, uh so it's a good repres you a good sample kit, you know, good representation of what's out there today.
You did a uh nice computer generated piece on the fifth.
Yeah, that was interesting.
Uh full parallax.
Yeah.
Um even Sony hasn't done a full parallax hologram yet.
Uh they're still doing horizontal parallax and um the idea itself is rather simple.
The engineering is a little tough, but we had Bob Hess, an expert holographer, work on that, and Chuck Hassan develop a uh full parallax printer and I'd love to see uh that you know done commercially because it got a good um good response from the readers.
So where's what's your next direction for Ross Books?
Well, we're uh the holography marketplace became an annual and uh we'd love to put out a quarterly at some point.
We're very heavy into uh spreading information over the internet.
Um we get worldwide inquiries about holography nearly every day.
And we we're basically book publishers, so we like to sell books.
Um I'm also writing articles for whoever's interested on the the latest and greatest holography information.
And we're gonna just keep plugging away.
We're um starting to expand our circulation, uh book clubs are starting to carry our book to get it out there.
We're going to a lot of conventions to get it into the users and potential users' hands.
Uh ad agencies, venture capitalist, uh technology companies, um advertising agencies, and just uh promote the whole holography industry.
That's our job.
Mm-hmm.
And you do it well.
We try.
You're the uh the force behind the motion of the field.
If we try.
You know, I had your I had your first uh edition of the holography marketplace and I can't find it anymore.
You should find it because that's worth upwards of five hundred dollars now.
No kidding I've I know it's around.
I've got everything going on back all the years.
I know it's here somewhere but I cannot find that first edition.
You know, just as kind of a joke because we're getting down to the last couple dozen and we said, well we're not gonna let's put a hundred dollar price tag on them.
Well book collectors found out about it.
These are people outside the holography industry because it has collectible holograms in there that'll never be reprinted the book is considered rare and collectible we start getting orders at a hundred dollars a piece that we're even contemplating doing a buyback at like seventy five.
So uh keep those old issues of holography marketplace and put them away so we can all put the kids through college.
I've got one in there now.
Okay.
Well what what else would you like to say before we wrap it up?
Uh just want to thank you for all your efforts through the years.
You're holding down the East Coast we're trying to hold down the West Coast and the Pacific rim, so if we all keep plugging away we'll all have jobs that we enjoy.
Uh stop sending that rain this way though.
Yeah yeah I I shouldn't say that to anyone on the West Coast I I realize you're all going through some pretty hard times out there with this uh weather this winter.
Well that's why I looked on the map and found out where there was a drought believe it or not it's Honolulu so I'm Hawaii bound.
Okay, well you have a good time on vacation.
It was good talking to you, Alan.
And folks, don't forget go over there and check out that Ross Books website.
It's W W W dot Rossbooks dot com and just click on the link that's on the HoloTalk page and that'll take you right over there.
Thank you, Alan.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Talk to you later.
Bye-bye.
Initiating shutdown sequence.